(bells ringing)
(chime music)
(people talking quietly)
- [Man] Four, and then
four, and then (indistinct).
(bells chiming)
(people cheering)
(clapping)
(people laughing)
(people cheering)
(people clapping)
(people laughing)
(people cheering)
(classical music)
- Good afternoon, Yale
College class of 2021.
(people cheering)
Welcome to the graduates
of Berkeley, Davenport,
Benjamin Franklin, and
Pauli Murray Colleges,
and welcome to family, friends,
and members of the class
who are joining us
virtually via livestream.
We are so excited to have
arrived at this special day.
In a few moments, we will
begin announcing the graduates
as they process across the
commencement stage here
in front of me, but before
we start our program,
a few words about the land on which
today's ceremony is taking place.
Yale acknowledges that
indigenous peoples and nations
including Mohegan, Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Schaghticoke, Golden
Hill Paugussett, Niantic
and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquin-speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations,
the lands and waterways
of what is now the state of Connecticut.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples
and nations and this land.
Thank you, and please enjoy the program.
(people applauding)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Berkeley College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale college.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in me,
I shall confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees
in Yale College, when
designated by the Dean
and shall then admit you to all
their rights and responsibilities.
- Ellen Margaret Andrews,
the banner bearer of Berkeley College.
Rachel Coile and Amy Zhang,
the procession marshals
of Berkeley College.
Pradhi Vinayak Aggarwal.
Colin Baciocco.
Jeniffer Leticia Banuelos.
Oishani Basuchoudhary.
Neha Bhatt.
Madelyn Blaney.
Kelvin Brobbey.
Grace Chen-Wei Chen.
Allison Seong-Yeon Chun.
Eduardo Custodio Leal.
James Foster Dunn.
Michelle Erdenesanaa.
Danielle Esposito.
Kelsey Olya Evans.
Abigail Virginia Fortier.
Tomeka Michelle Frieson.
William J. Gallagher.
Ohshue Shane Gatanaga.
Joan Gomez-Aguilar.
Danielle Harris.
Lydia Bross Hill.
Julian Johnson.
Charlotte Kavaler.
Caleb Hyun Kim.
Ananya Kumar-Banerjee.
Sooyong Kwon.
Claire Elizabeth Laffan.
Olivia Levieux.
Alice Li.
Brian Lin.
Genevieve Suskind Liu.
Henry C. Liu.
David Loong.
Timothy Larsson Luz.
Zepei Ma.
Caroline Lewis Magavern.
Zev A. Mayer.
Tanvi Mihir Mehta.
Helena Maria Mileo.
William Thayer Mitchell.
Bryanna Ariel Moore.
Lynn Vi Nguyen.
Chaz Okada.
Bryan Oliveira.
Qusay Omran.
Daniel O'Reilly.
Anthony M. Orr.
Bryan Lu Owens.
Allegra O. Pankratz.
Amar Patel.
Kathryn Ora Paton.
Alladia Kali Fakir Patterson.
Nathan Paumier.
Victoria Isabel Quintanilla.
Brian Reyes.
Andrew St. Claire Richards.
Marissa Rivera.
Daud Shad.
Veronica Sosa.
William Arthur Sussman.
Mary Tate.
Washakie Tibbetts.
Austin Zong Tuan.
Anisa A. Vashi.
Irene Vázquez.
Candice Wang.
Michael Whalen.
Andy Xie.
Annie Yang.
Mary Jacqueline Yap.
Joanna Zukin.
And the graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations, Berkeley class of 2021.
(people applauding)
- Mr. President, I have the honor
to present candidates
from Pauli Murray College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the Dean
and shall then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Severyn Kushmeliuk,
banner bearer for Pauli Murray College.
Lincoln Thatcher Berkeley
and Ileana Sophia Valdez,
procession marshals of
Pauli Murray College.
Mauro Aceves-Acosta.
Aakshi Agarwal.
Alya Khaleel Ahmed.
Amer Ahmad Al-Hiyasat.
Ahmed Allawi.
Krista Naomi Arellano.
Ekrem Melih Ayhan.
Jackson Robert Bandow.
Ornella Ihirwe Bayigamba.
Adrian Bebenek.
Hanna Blankemeier.
Michael Philip Blicher.
Sam Isaac Kaim Brakarsh.
Brandon Ronald Chambers.
Felicia Chang.
Michael Yon-Joon Chang.
James Joseph Check.
Pei Hua Chen.
Esther Yuna Choi.
Ryley Drew Constable.
Hunter Ryan Contos.
Lukas Robert Corey.
Christian Ryan Cropp.
Gaole Dai.
Kiran Matthew Damodaran.
John Bassel Sameh Daoud.
Daniel Joseph Diprimio.
Amelia Lynn Drake.
Yara Nour El-Khatib.
Matthew John Erickson.
Lucas Curry Ferrer.
Heather Jane Foster.
Chris Eugene Fowler, Jr.
Mila Freeman.
Kevin Paul Gallagher, Jr.
Yasheen Gao.
Griffin Douglas Gharrity.
Patrycja Aneta Gorska.
Jordan Adam Grode.
Leila Halley-Wright.
Samuel Seunghyun Han.
Kevin Hong.
Sarah Anne Jordan.
Alexander Julicher.
Naasey Kanko Arthur.
Nash Doris Bonfield Keyes.
Tasnia Khan.
Alexander Kirov.
Jacquelyn Elizabeth Knobelsdorf.
Kate Hypatia Kushner.
Julia Morgan Leatham.
Kyoung A Viola Lee.
Justin Weaver Lilley.
Claudia Loiacono.
Tessa Violet Malone.
Danielle Martin.
Richard Molu Mbouombouo.
Kathryn Miyawaki.
Anaheed Lahl Mobaraki.
Sarah Michele Monahan.
Hannah Rae Moreno.
Emma Joan Meuller.
Osariemen Pricllia Ogbemudia.
Claire Margaret O'Mara.
Jude Anthony Salada Ong.
Natalie Dorzeide Orner.
Mitchell Benjamin Ostrow.
Joshua Glenn Palmer
Rowan Mackenzie Palmer.
Yo Han John Park.
Ryan Patrick Parkey.
Amanda Lloyd Patterson.
Phuah Hui En Shannon.
Kaitlynn Taylor Pineda.
Jordan Powell.
Elizabeth Anne Qian-Wang.
Keshav Aditya Raghavan.
Andrew Paul Reardon.
Steven Michael Reilly.
Emily Margaret Richards.
Cesar Rodriguez.
Emma Lark Ruohoniemi.
Maxwell Naddaff Sahlins.
Kevin Omar Sanaycela.
Anthony Enrique Dani Sarkiss.
Lydia Bennett Shaw.
Renee Anna Su.
Katherine Wenxi Sun.
Benjamin Kyle Tillinger.
Michelle Kristina Tong.
Gabriel Vasquez.
Nicholas Landon Wade.
Daniel Zhenghan Wang.
Skye Alexandra De La Vergne Ward.
Laura Lee Wayland.
Amira Kali Williams.
Tiffany Wong.
Reese Maxwell Wynn.
Jonathan Alex Xu.
Hiu Lam Vanessa Yan.
Sean Yi.
Claire Kelly Zalla.
Yi Zeng Zhang.
Angela Zhao.
Sophia Zhao.
And the graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
From Prof. T and me, much LiMur love.
Congratulations to the inaugural class
of Pauli Murray College.
(people cheering)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Davenport College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
The Bachelor's degrees in Yale College
when designated by the Dean,
and shall then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Jason Bradley Campe and Eda Naz Dinc,
the banner bearers of Davenport College.
Chelsea Nicole Ilarde
and Alyssa Jisu Yoon,
the precession marshals
of Davenport College.
Ayodimeji Oreoluwa Abiola.
Joan Chika Agoh.
Cameron James Fisher Allen.
Rohan Sangamesh Angadi.
Babak Badiey.
Jessica Yoonju Bae.
Clay Andrew Bailey II.
Steven Dennis Barbee.
Alexandra A. Bauman.
Ameera Elizabeth Billings.
Victoria Bonano.
Robert Anthony Brinkmann.
Joshua Collier Brooks.
Nicole Erin Presgrave Brussel Faria.
Maxwell G. Bu.
Natalia Castellanos Gonzalez.
Xiafangzhou Chao.
Alan Cong-xi Chen.
Julia C. Chertkof.
Graylen Ray Chickering.
Ariel Elena Claxton.
Danielle Alexis Collins.
Sekou Li Conde.
Patrick Lawrence Conte.
Nicholas Ryan Dahl.
Cosette Elizabeth Davis.
Amy C. Delabruere.
Lauren Nicole Drysch.
Jenesis Victoria Duran.
Nathalie Anne Marie Eid.
Epongue Wei-Dikaki Ekille.
Noah David Gershenson.
Chloe Alexandra Heller.
Henderson Edward Heussner.
Caleb T. Hillrich.
Christopher James Hladczuk.
Alexander West Hiser Hoban.
Lucas Joachim Holter.
Emily Rose Howell.
Amanda Ibanez.
Abdulla Ebrahim Mohamed Ahmed Janahi.
Conor W.K. Johnson.
Nikita Joshi.
Hasna Saeeda Karim.
Angele Christian Kelly.
Jonathan George Kraft.
Morgan Ellie Lawson.
Alexis K. Lazor.
Bu Liu.
Nicholas Moran Macnab.
Canning Livia Malkin.
Daniel James Marsh.
Gema Martinez Castillo.
Ethan David McBride.
William Francis McGahan II.
Bryan Mendoza.
Christian A. Milian-Santiago.
Muhammad Imraan Munshi.
Peter Howard Neugebauer.
Anne Cooper Nields.
Orlando McMillan Nixon.
Onyeditachi Onuoha.
Matthew Holman Peel.
Megan Leigh Quimby.
Maya Haley Raiford Cohen.
Raj K. Ramnani.
Katelyn Eileen Reese.
Daniel Thomas Robinson.
Katerina Paola Robles.
Roba Sabawi.
Matthew Phillip Sáenz.
Niam M. Shah.
Neelam Iyer Shaikh.
Iram Afrien Sharieff.
Lauren Hallie Singer.
Talia Anne Pearlman Soglin.
Kevin X. Tang.
Sydney Richelle Terroso.
Caitlin Elisabeth Tycz.
Divine Ihuaku Uchegbu.
Ryan Patrick Vollmer.
Isabel Skye Wanner.
Jason Nathaniel Weinstein.
Kesi K. Wilson.
Jaccaranda Petros Woldemariam.
Nathan Shaw Wu.
Angela Yoo.
Florentin Audley Zander.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations, Davenport class of 2021.
(people cheering)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Benjamin Franklin College
for the Bachelor's
degrees of Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College
when designated by the Dean,
and shall then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Tyler Joseph Jansen,
banner bearer for
Benjamin Franklin College.
Beamlak Ashenafi, Abigail Eswarakumar,
marshals for the procession
of Benjamin Franklin College.
Camara Aaron.
Wasil Ahmed.
Victoria Dawn Andrew.
Paul St. Aubyn Atkinson, Jr.
Thalia Baeza Milan.
Jaylen Russell Bailey.
Stephanie Bang.
Sarah Elizabeth Baskin.
Kiran Baucom.
Cristina Paz Bermudez.
Evan, Christopher Blasy
Ivana Bozic.
Jordan Carey.
Mina Cezairli.
T. Victoria Chen.
Colton Ford Conley.
Jason Louis Contino.
Isabel Silva Corpus.
Lauren Nicole Cueto.
Emma Rose Desrochers.
Benjamin Clifford Lee Dormus,
Fred Junior Ebongue Makolle.
Ayah Elmansy.
Madeleine Freeman.
Tony Gao.
Charles Harrison Gardner.
Angela Gong.
Carolina Sofia Gonzalez Zapata.
Spencer Chase Hagaman.
Morgan Hanna Ghattas.
Amanda Debra Hartzell.
Maximilian Piet Himpe.
Oona O'Neill Holahan.
Sydney Lauryn Holmes.
Mina Grace Hughes.
Arthur Hwang.
Christopher Irsfeld.
Isabel Elise Johnson.
Jiyoung Kang.
Leo Khazan.
Mihir Khunte.
Kelsey Grace Kissane.
Jessica Ling Kong.
Isabel Koolik.
Mimi Kostoska.
Sylvia Kryszcuk.
Makayla Terèse Laronde-King.
Olivia Lee.
Sasha Lee.
Sara Melanie Lewis.
Katharine Li.
Shannon Ross Linder.
Lauren Elise Lo Coco.
Layla Lopez.
Melat Genene Lulseged.
Adam Jeffrey Madievsky.
Gunasheil Mandava.
Frederic-Louis Zachary Montas.
Talia Nash Coon Morison-Allen.
Liviu Mosnoi.
Juliette Catherine Neil.
Iragi Nkera.
Emma Caroline Osborne.
Joseph Ostuno.
Eric Ou.
Joseph Peck.
Patrick Perry.
Thomas Postiglione.
Caroline Pryor.
Kathryn Pundyk.
Michael Purvey, Jr.
Aldo Eugenio Quevedo.
Cindy Waner Ren.
Imani Richardson.
Logan Rivers.
Meera Rothman.
Zachary Austin Rudner.
Abeera Saeed.
Isabel Sands.
Francesco Mario Carlo Scarpetta.
Isaiah Schrader.
Jonathan Schwartz.
Vienna Gloria Scott.
Benjamin Shelley.
Donovan Slater.
Alexa Stanger.
Paul Stankey.
Faith Vasquez
Tricia Viveros.
Gwendolyn Maya Wallace.
Kathleen Segovia Wells.
Lisa Wu.
Amanda Zhang.
Namra Zulfiqar.
Andres Colunga.
And our graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations, Benjamin Franklin.
(people cheering)
- So to the students of the Class of 2021
and their parents, families and friends
looking on from around the globe,
we gather to recognize the
extraordinary accomplishments
of all of you who have worked so hard
to complete your programs of study.
We salute your effort, your diligence,
your talent, and your intellect.
We also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported
you in these endeavors.
Your families and friends, teachers,
and other members of the Yale community.
Congratulations, Class of 2021.
(people cheering)
- Hello, Class of 2021.
I'm Brian Owens, your class secretary.
Four years have gone by
in the blink of an eye.
We've made so many memories,
from the first year
snowball fight on Old Campus right here,
to the 2019 Yale-Harvard game,
which we won in double overtime,
to the late nights, whether
they be in the library
studying for an exam
or in the common room,
talking with our suite-mates and friends.
Although our senior year experience
has not been a traditional
one, the Class of 2021
has made the best of the situation.
When we leave Yale in just a few days,
we will leave with
memories and friendships
that last a lifetime.
Here's to the Class of 2021. We did it.
(people cheering)
- Class of 2021, good afternoon.
My name is Skye Ward, and I am a member
of the committee that organized Class Day,
which will air on YouTube
tomorrow at 2:30 PM
two minutes before two 30 at 2:28 PM,
a special piece written
by Class Day speaker
Robert Lopez will be
played from Harkness Tower,
so keep your ears open.
If you haven't already
decorated a funny hat
for Class Day, it's not too late.
In fact, on your seat today, you received
a Class Day 2021 hat that
you might want to use
for that purpose.
You'll also find a gift
bag, which includes items
that represent long-standing
Class Day traditions,
as well as others that are new
and unique to the class of 2021.
In addition to the Class Day speaker,
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class who put together
outstanding original speeches.
And because Class Day is about all of us,
you'll see your own photographs
and video reflections
throughout tomorrow's program.
Congratulations, class of
2021, and see you at Class Day.
(people applauding)
- Class of 2021, congratulations.
I am so happy to be with you
and to celebrate with you today.
Graduating is a great accomplishment,
one of the most important
ones of your life.
If you think back to when
you first arrived on campus,
though, no one could have
imagined that you would
live through a global pandemic
before reaching this moment,
but you did, and thanks to
your strength and perseverance,
this moment has finally come.
I'm honored to recognize all the work
that you have done to get here, much of it
with the support of
your family and friends.
today's your day, and it is theirs too.
Today's a day for looking back with pride
at everything you have accomplished
and all the goals you have reached.
Of course, it brings some sadness too,
now that you are ending
your bright college years,
but today's a commencement, a beginning.
So now as you look to
the days and years ahead,
think of the new achievements
and opportunities
in front of you, and look around as well
to remind yourself of
the excellent company
joining on this new beginning,
your friendships formed at Yale.
Tomorrow you will celebrate Class Day,
a tradition stretching back 150 years
in Yale College history.
I'm excited to watch the
virtual program alongside you,
and on Monday we can look forward
to President Salovey's
Commencement address.
I am grateful to the Class Day committee,
to the senior class
council, to the University
Secretary's Office, to your
college heads and deans,
and to everyone who contributed to making
the special events of
this weekend possible.
And I'm most appreciative to you,
for all that you have brought to Yale
and will now bring out
to the world with you.
Again, class of 2021, congratulations
(people applauding)
(classical music)
(upbeat music)